[Music]
first of all our happy Valentine now I
got some exciting news for the first
time ever you can text me on the number
below and I will help sort out all those
problems across dinner tonight making
sure your Valentine's night becomes a
dream and not a nightmare hi Gordon my
husband's in the military and I'll be
alone this Valentine's Day
oh I'm sorry Stephanie now I've already
made some bomb-ass naki I'm Italian and
I rule my kitchen what should I make for
dessert for myself you know
I don't just care if I'm so fat I hate
myself tonight
give me something decadent please right
Stephanie let's send you a little
message
hi Stephanie hope you're happy Levantine
on your own tonight for dessert I would
do the most amazing tiramisu which means
pick me up good luck god bless and lot's
of luck
I got a perm xington going to make spicy
tuna poke Eva Valentine's insides sounds
great not too
please
you'll ruin the two
poof
there are thousands Carly what kind of
helped I guess cooking or love advice
Jesus girl
really Wow behave yourself thanks for
being available tonight for your fans
there my question is when you're cooking
lobster thermidors is it better to use
heavy whipping cream or just creme
fraiche thanks writes let's go and do
you a little message good evening
happy Valentine whipping cream liquid
too heavy especially lobster I would use
creme fraiche a little bit of acidic
with some lime or lemon that sounds
amazing
don't overcook that lobster so basically
don't get it too hot or the one become
rubbery a good luck and happy Valentine
again
Gordon helped settle the votes is it
basil or basil
Jesus Christ is battle you donut
is
come on [ __ ] sake stop basil it's basil
you donut how many times have to tell
you
[Music]
[Music]